today we're talking about google
workspace cloud functions
and the google maps platform i'm reto
meier and welcome to this week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news
from the safety at home introducing
google workspace everything you need to
get anything done now in one place
google workspace includes all of our
productivity apps like gmail calendar
and drive
now with three main upgrades first a new
deeply integrated user experience that
helps teams collaborate more effectively
second a new brand identity that
reflects the way our products work
together
and third new ways to get started with
solutions and price points tailored to
the unique needs of our broad range of
customers
cloud functions recently leveled up now
supporting new runtimes new regions and
fine grained security controls
there's also new support for local
development with the functions framework
an
upgraded code editor in the cloud
console and more ways to control your
costs
it's a long list of new features and
services so be sure to check out the
blog post
for a full recap 2020 has certainly been
a year of unexpected challenges and the
upcoming holiday shopping season will
likely see a few more
with the increased focus on contactless
shopping and order pickup it's a good
time to focus on the omnichannel
shopping experience
to help the google maps platform has two
retail solutions
store locator plus and checkout and this
blog
covers how you can leverage these
services to drive conversions
season three of seasons of scale kicked
off with carter morgan explaining how to
break apps into independent services and
aim for a stateless cloud solution
so be sure to check out the video to
follow along as critter junction
choose which monolithic apps should be
refactored into microservices
and how stateless services made that
easier if you want to read more about
these announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud